it's time to babble buck-buck lie from
the Jon Lovitz podcast theater its
Hollywood babble-on
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman
[Music]
I was trying to do before we turn the
music down theme lasts it's so [ __ ]
long long cream we got out we'll get
hours of that has it always been like
that into a home I'm show up here we
could just have that underneath this all
night long it is Saturday night in the
Hollywood so let's babble the [ __ ] I am
the stoner Kevin Smith obviously and I'm
the drunk Ralph Garman welcome thanks
for coming out folks unite nice being
here man
I just carted ass all the way over from
[ __ ] Santa Monica I went to a event
where JJ Abrams says that bad robot
production is he had a this event where
what's the dude's name who doesn't score
Michael Giacchino Yeah right I think
that's how you pronounce those name I
was just there and I didn't listen
it had like more than two syllables and
I was like [ __ ] that so he had this
whole Orchestra on a roof of bad robot
and they played all this music from like
bad robot stuff from like super 8 lot of
super 8 stuff
he played submission impossible from the
recent Mission Possible lost it was
quite lovely man it was in there you
could throw a rock hit a [ __ ] famous
person I saw Ben Affleck he did not say
hi everybody I nobody was with his wife
oh that explains it
Jennifer hates you I guess thank you sir
but in any event it was really really
sweet man was cool and then I went
because I you know I like JJ he's a nice
guy but my kid [ __ ] loves super 8
like you read about like like the way I
loved Empire Strikes Back when I was a
kid that's the way she loves super a she
knows all the dialogue and she's like
it's crazy so she wants to go to the
event because there was the musical
portion then afterwards they have been
having a screening and a QA with the
cast and the director and I was like oh
you want to go see another directors QA
and she's like yeah I'm relatively sure
JJ Abrams isn't gonna talk about my
mother's [ __ ]
and I was like [ __ ] you man that's how
daddy earns didn't super8 come out like
two years ago
yeah a long time it felt like an awards
kind of like hey hey hey everybody
remember this I mean when you're outside
in the air playing music and walking in
Santa Monica and yeah a bunch of voters
out there I'm like that's pretty what's
that you know later on it was very it
was it was nice that was very sweet but
the kid I had to leave to race over here
man the Q&A hadn't started yet
they were just about to get gone like I
bumped into the chick that wanted a
Fanning's the one of the Dakota well she
was now yeah yeah I was gonna go be see
I was going through the alphabet in my
head but they were about to special an
oscillating fan pretty much oscillating
huge fan
the I got to see the beginning got in a
car came the [ __ ] over here to do
Hollywood better oh thanks that's my kid
they're just realize she has no ride
home but she'll be fine she's 12 year
old directing clerks to fat to fly
couldn't give me a ride well thanks for
coming imagine if you had told your
daughter we have to leave because I do
Hollywood babble and she would not have
appreciated ya does it come with me I'm
gonna go tell [ __ ] jokes at a bar yeah
well I just rushed over here from Studio
City I was changing a shitty diaper so
we had similar evenings kinda we're
watching a grand orchestral performance
yes I was smelling baby [ __ ] so I'm glad
[Music]
under your tail little kimbap there and
we changed her diaper we start off the
show every week with shout outs of
people who have come particularly long
distances or celebrating special
occasions to spend the evening here with
us and we do good
it's just a perfect blend of the
lemonade and ice team and well done
whoever put this one together my
compliments to the chef
I'm in the middle of a setup here and
you you stop the show for an Arnie
Palmer you're talking about shoutouts I
wanted to give one this is an amazing
Arnold Palmer big shadow you're an
easily impressed young man tonight yes
yes
anyway we got a theme for it and
everything it's called shout outs
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not even gonna look I'm not I reven
want to know what's going on over there
I got it by the way this is an excellent
mix of Jack Daniels and ice - whoever
did this just the right amount of straw
I like that all right let's talk about
shoutouts is uh Scott and the David here
hello Scott and the David oh thank you
there's a note attached usually some
itthat's thrown through my window when
there's a note attached dear Ralph I've
stolen your kidney No
call 911 ice this drink is for the one
and only Laquisha
shut up Snooki from the sitch for those
listening who don't live in the
Southland here in Southern California I
do a character on the radio called
Laquisha do you really yes she is she is
a african-american woman who reviews
reality television for the morning show
team that I work with can we get a taste
[Applause]
well I'll give her this drink backstage
thank you
anyway where were we Scott and the David
came all the way from San Francisco
California my name is Scott I'm
traveling with my friend but David not
to not to start in right away because
I'm only a drink and a half into the
show but the David your nickname is the
David evidently your name's David but
they call you the David I'm the David
man the David like the Fonz or the
instead of traveling down five 101 or
PCH Scott writes we took the scenic
route and traveled down to Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] they took the long way I was pretty
wasted the other day while listening to
your New Year's Eve show in the middle
of the show my roommate let me know that
our TV was busted so facing the weekend
without ps3 I called the David and
suggested we road trip to see your show
to which he replied [ __ ] yeah
all right the David thanks for all the
free funny Scott and the David well
thanks for making the trip all the way
down from San Francisco gentlemen we
appreciate that no that should be our
new tagline Hollywood babble-on we're
better than a broken TV of the Ralph
thing she's the route thanks you Mike
and charity Smith
I think you just solved the Kennedy
murder for Mike just shouted Joe
DiMaggio killed Kennedy is that right is
that is that a true theory oh it sounded
good for a sec yeah he's just a shank in
the line drives out of the window in the
Book Depository and beam Kennedy in the
head Mike and charity Smith back into
the left field he pointed before he hit
him my wife and our huge fan of the
podcast and she let me plan our entire
honeymoon around coming to the show on
January 7th nice nice
why don't you guys get married
congratulations man yeah got married out
here did you oh that's mark is out here
she'd take half in my house Morton halfe
yeah I hear that all the time she's
always I was like yeah I get it you'll
take half she's like well start with
have no prenup dude no no I want in like
that just seemed kind of phony to me
it's just like I'm gonna love you
forever but if not through this piece of
paper so me I was just remembering my
lawyer - he was just like you're are you
getting married this weekend like cuz it
was a spur-of-the-moment thing we were
up at Skywalker Ranch mixing Dogma right
and she was already pregnant she was
eight months pregnant with Harley and
she almost forgot her name there for a
minute didn't you like that was like
which one of my kids I was like I only
have one Harley and she's also beautiful
up here she's like we should I'd be a
great place to get married I was like
yeah totally should get married here one
day and she was like I meant us I was
like oh yeah we should yeah and then she
was like what about this weekend I was
like I'm okay we pulled it together very
very [ __ ] quickly so [ __ ] I forgot
why I was even telling this story
your lawyer found out you're alright so
there we are thank you yeah so there we
are about to get married like smudges up
there with me and he's my best man a
friend of Jen's lived in the Bay Area so
she came over and she was gonna be her
maid of honor and my I talked to my I
was talking to my lawyer about something
completely unrelated and I was like hey
man by the way you remember you
Jen he's like yeah I love it I was like
we're gonna get married up here at Scott
Walker he's like what and I was again
working we decided we're gonna get
married just kind of elope to it real
quick we got this Dutch Catholic monk to
come up and marry us and [ __ ] dramatic
community otally absolutely all the way
he was he was [ __ ] badass he loved the
matrix he'd quote the matrix and the
sermon he's like take the blue Jesus's
take the blue pill you know he seemed
very cool and then I thought he was so
cool I showed him first cut a dog man he
was just like this is sick it wasn't
that cool anymore but any of that he
came over to Marius at the place and
[ __ ] so I tell my lawyer this is again
it's Dutch Catholic monks gonna come
over marries and he and my lawyer goes I
hate to be this guy but I'm your lawyer
you sure you don't want to throw prenup
in there real quick I could fax you
something very fast that she could sign
and I was just like oh God the notion of
like hey man I love you my baby's inside
he were about to tie ourselves together
here at [ __ ] Skywalker man like look
there's an Ewok we were in a room where
there was furniture where I was like
I've spent so much money on Star Wars
[ __ ] I probably bought that chair you
know so I felt like this is a great
place too and then suddenly I'd present
this [ __ ] paper and I was like no no
let's [ __ ] do it if it all blew apart
at the end of the day I always felt like
she'd be entitled to at least actually
you know the kid she brought the kid
into the world right so so far so good
there was no prenup and she's never kind
of imploded yet but every once in a
while whenever we talk to were kind of
joke about divorce she always lets me
know very [ __ ] quickly that v
California 50% you know is a myth it's
really the [ __ ] Schwalbach 98% the
starting point yeah yeah that's where
you begin anyway all right back to the
ship mica charity I planned their
honeymoon around coming down here Mike
as you can see I set the bar pretty low
in order to prepare my bride for a
lifetime of lowered expectations very
wise smart blow man in a way could be
said that Kevin helped to bring us
together because our love of his films
and SModcast we met online and that's
one of the very first things we found we
had in common we both agreed that no one
could get killed by a giant CG tentacle
like Ralph well thank you very much damn
you shark the book
but no [ __ ] gonna get that reaction
would've done a better read I thought
she was talking about some gay porn she
saw you in it that was a real tentacle
that wasn't CG damn you octopus yeah I
saw the balls you don't need to
emphasize cradle the balls we're driving
all the way from Ogden Utah to make it
to the show you came you guys drove in
from Utah today well we're not Mormon
but her family is but there's no [ __ ]
way they'll ever hear this so it doesn't
matter that's true they provide a lot of
Mormon listeners to Babylon I'm thinking
we can find out right now everyone show
us your onesies who's wearing magic
underwear in the crowd tonight anyone
eating jello while we speak that said
after smoking a bowl and having
premarital sex one night we thought it
would be great if Ralph Pete was a
shouted as pee-wee Herman congratulating
us on our nuptials Mike and Charlie
Smith called you're married Chad
silverstein Chad are you in the crowd
hold on before we jump into that I wish
I could do impressions like you man I
would never be lonely again you just
talk to yourself and different boys hey
just think about like you could sit
there and ask pee-wee for advice and
[ __ ] yeah but you know it's not really
peewee it's just me doing the voice of
feeling doesn't matter it does though
know them because they put you in a home
if you start doing the voices to
yourself
still do in front of people man this is
for like a long time yeah like you could
literally get jerked off by pee-wee
Herman yeah I don't want first of all
first of all he went to jail I think
about for that think about all the
people that could jerk you all yes
Charlton Heston he could yes
Oh behave what's his [ __ ] Austin
Powers yeah he could do it
ooh Al Pacino you could do it now I
don't know their names like this mr.
catchphrase
Edwin could jerk you off he could yes
David Bowie the list goes on and on I
could only get jerked off by Kevin Smith
yeah but you man you run the gamut yeah
oh my goodness you need more Lube Adam
West Adam West could jerk me off like he
Hazzard I kid speaking of which plug the
show oh yeah
January 28th the three weeks from
tonight on this very stage at 8:00 p.m.
it's the early show we'll be doing an
evening with Adam West right up here
he'll be sitting across from me we're
gonna talk about his entire life and
career Batman and Family Guy and all the
other stuff that he's done we're
celebrating his he's finally getting his
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame so
we're raising some money to help pay for
[Music]
one of those things like if you had told
the the ten year old me that I was going
to be friends with and sharing a stage
with Adam West not only that he would he
would be if you could go back in time
and say to the 10 year old Ralph Carmen
like one day we're gonna be grown up
Batman
and grownup Robin and help Batman get a
star yeah and then ten year old Ralph
would be like what the [ __ ] happened to
our hair
he would ask me that yeah ten-year-old
Ralph would be like I see we never get
out of the leopard jacket I had a very
little real attack of age to wear when I
was 10
Chad silverstein Chad's over there right
Chad hey Chad Oh
Chad the Chad came from Auburn
California near Sacramento and I made
travel plans to come down to LA to visit
family I told my dad we had to come see
this show with him being of the hobbled
variety I am hoping to capitalize on his
[ __ ] eNOS to parlay it into floor seats
what he used to take Kathy Bates or
something this is dad handi-capable he's
got a cane okay I met you man we met in
the elevator
we were chit-chatting but we were in the
elevator coming up from downstairs and
he goes my son knew I was in the
elevator with you and I said tell you
what and I gave him a buck I said tell
your son that I gave him a dollar just
because it would make it a better story
man yeah Kevin Smith's Jeep that's the
story now Onofre Buck is a free book in
1953 maybe I just get water change you
had in your pocket what do you
but I wasn't beholden to give anything
it was not something you know crank up a
20 spot or something be a mensch
that's my Jewish friends say you're a
real dick Ralph it was a beautiful
moment you're like you should have given
more memorable Kevin Smith gave me out
now I'm Jerry Lewis that's your best one
yet Kevin Smith man of 1 voices no Jerry
Lewis hey now I'm Jimmy Stewart oh you
you sure are mean mr. Potter as long as
you said the guy's name that's true dad
wants you to know Kevin that he supports
your band your policy against Southwest
Airlines thank you sir dad says my
return trip to Auber on Sunday I'll be
at the Burbank Airport at 7:00 a.m. to
catch a bus I was spending all day from
7 a.m. to 5 p.m. on four different buses
and trains to show solidarity against
Southwest and their person of sighs
policies hey you might want to take the
plane yeah I don't hate him that much
that's a lot of bus that's a lot of bus
time yeah and dad with the limp and
everything that's not fair he stays here
oh you live here oh then Chad's
traveling alone on a bus that's even
sadder
my dad says HBO is going to be on par
with most of Kevin's flicks filth wise
could you break it to him gently what
kind of debauchery is in for this
evening no we'll surprise him Natalie
the show is being I'm sorry I didn't
mean to interrupt your tangent with some
show Kevin you had something no not
anymore
wanna give me a buck
a buck is not what I want to give you
right now you're witnessing the final at
how about by the wall Natalie and RJ you
guys in the crowds sorry to make you
scream twice
my boyfriend RJ and I are excited to be
attending the January 7th show we are
big fans and celebrating RJ's winning a
first-place prize at the Slamdance Film
Festival this year
rats graduations RJ you hiring actors RJ
buddy James contrary to popular belief I
can actually speak dialogue keep me in
mind for your next project won't you if
you need a reference call me are you
tucking the tablecloth into your pants
oh is do it is I try to get cozy AB tuck
up like a blanket I do you never know
always very disturbing I don't know
what's going on underneath the
tablecloth a little bit of pee-wee
Herman yeah RJ knows my pee-wee Herman
impression on people Herman I'm jerking
on RJ and I will be double its level yes
it is Natalie ads RJ and I will be
heading to the festival at the end of
this month to see his short film on the
big screen
right on man it would be awesome dance
you're going to slam dance at the end of
this month
right gratulations so wait you got into
slam dance and it hasn't played yet it's
about to debut this year
beautiful Congrats well [ __ ] awesome
maker in the room
oh well one it would be awesome if you
can graduate him with a musical round of
Al Pacino's more margarita mix and a few
words of encouragement from mr. Pacino
himself I think we can accommodate James
[Applause]
I want to work with you cuz after doing
a movie with Adam Sandler I'll work with
anybody come on now with the Jack and
Jill whoa uh-oh
that was [ __ ] didn't it break your heart
a little bit we saw Al Pacino was doing
Jack and Jill uh break her a little bit
I mean no I know Al's been on the one
for the money I'm sorry too for the
money that's right yeah what the
Katherine Heigl movie that's coming out
it's the prequel to to from the money
I'm not in that one no it takes place
before my character put on the leather
jacket to for the money's named movie I
did with this and it was a fine film
yeah no matter what the audience's and
the critics said Ali Irvine Ali
Holly look at all the tattoos you have I
don't mean to draw attention to yourself
conscious about them but you couldn't
because they're all over your body I
can't see stand up she's not it's not a
sideshow sir
she just happens to be ordained and
ordained jabba's me ornately decorated
it's very attractive sorry father Ali
Ali is here to celebrate her 25th
birthday oh happy birthday I was here
last week for New Year's Eve Babylon
which was amazing except I was on the
third floor next to the [ __ ] who
would not stop shouting
that was my wait are you talking we have
to show no impersonations necessary
happy birthday from you and Kevin will
make this night perfect well happy
birthday 25 what are you gonna do with
this year what is it go to school what
are you studying illustration and fine
art you've been practicing on your arms
apparently do fine work let's give her
life advice life advice yeah 25 man it's
quarter of a century that deserves some
piece of advice more so than like happy
birthday here's the best advice I could
give you [ __ ] I learned in 41 years
whenever you're sitting at a table with
a tablecloth
[Laughter]
well when you're sitting at the table
with someone don't look to what they're
doing
beneath the waist it's better that you
don't know 25 I wish somebody give him
the advice of 25 I pissed away the
better part of my 20s with cocaine and
alcohol it's really yeah and the better
part of my thirties quite frankly but
but it was it was fun but I could have
been more productive area man I'm not
making movies I did I pissed away the
better part of my twenties man clerks
what a waste
I was I was bartending and doing big fat
lines and getting getting blown in the
liquor room is that what would go on
yeah what was his name how dare you sir
I had fun but I feel like I would be
further along in my career if I had been
like Ali had been more productive know
what come to this show on your 25th
birthday instead of getting blown in the
bathroom yes I think you did just fine
don't do
how about Ross Ross and Kylie Ross and
Kylie and Alex and branded and Ashley oh
it's just that just a cornucopia of
drunkards over there huh that is a lot
of names from like the turn of the
century yes we didn't I didn't go to
school with any Alex's Brandon's
Ashley's and certainly no [ __ ]
Kylie's how about a Ross Ross no no as a
matter of fact no it sounds like the
cast of a new CW show tonight on city
wok Heat Kylie and Ross meet up with
Alex and Brandon hoping Ashley doesn't
find out oh man it's [ __ ] Kylie Alex
Brandon ash see if I could do two
seconds from now
Kylie Alex Brandon edge that show would
work memorable rolls off the tongue
Ross writes my one-and-only birthday
wish I'm by the way they're here to
celebrate his birthday did I mention
that oh yeah we left him at Ross Ross is
the writer of these a guest star he's
the upstairs neighbor maze-like mr.
Furley is like isn't he gay my only one
my one and only birthday wish is to have
him is to have Kevin let me play an
extra in his new hockey film right I
already play hockey
so it wouldn't be much of a stretch in
terms of acting sweet the only
requirement is that I have at least one
line so I can tell all my friends and
family that I have one more line than
Ralph Garman did in red stick
I see how it's gonna be Ross all right
yeah you can shut up if it helps Kevin
in this decision I just found out that I
had cancer we call it candy hearsay and
that the only cure for this particular
kind of cancer would be to have a single
line as an extra in this hockey thumb
which would give me more star power than
Ralph Garman seeing as his one line in
red state mysteriously disappeared
[ __ ] you lost twice place with that shot
all kidding aside Ross writes seriously
cancer love Ross Woods PS Bill Cosby
doing the creepy clown song to Kevin may
also cure the cancer well maybe I don't
want to cure your cancer Ross maybe I'd
like to see you die painfully in a
hospital I'm a little intrigued by the
notion of the Bill Cosby version of the
clown well I'll do it for you but I
won't do it
[Laughter]
there you go Bill Cosby putting on white
paint new clown is Cosby you're not
scared no it's a dream you scared it's
[Music]
amazing this email comes from Kylie
Ross's wife did everyone write a [ __ ]
email yours is special Ralphie Kevin I
rub my husband Roz already emailed you
about us being there for his birthday
but I decided to email you as well
because we got you presents you should
definitely read my email one so I can
give you the presents to because I'm
wearing a good cleavage shirt we'll be
the judge of that Kylie that is a pretty
good good cleavage shirt do you have
presents this one's Kevin what is a
pitch it up here now that's a little a
little a little day chain that is a
there's a life-sized Kevin Smith [ __ ]
feature look at that these are [ __ ]
straws for Kevin to put in his delicious
tasting Arnold Palmer I will use this
right now oh don't put a cop straw you
drink
[Applause]
the [ __ ] novelty this young has a new
thoughtful and practical yes oh thank
you I like that it is a clown hand
puppet and the only thing creepier than
actual clowns in my opinion are clown
puppets
[Laughter]
look at this we could do anatomically
correct clown now that's scary clown
they can blow himself we should make
this mandatory people have to bring a
[ __ ] every hour this is amazing thank
you thank you for the gifts Kylie we
appreciate ya thank you for your ample
bosom as well Overmind this [ __ ]
boring old straw
you've got the expandable [ __ ] straw you
should do a late night TV infomercial
another swallower
[Laughter]
are you tired drinking out of the same
old straws try new Kevin Smith [ __ ]
straws it's delicious we hit makes
chocolate milk tastes better couple of
nine-year-olds makes fizzy drinks cheesy
drinks come one come on
now I'll get the new ball cups we get
emails from around the world we have
some tonight Jay
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions
hi Ralph and cameras watching some of
the special features on the Doctor Who
series 5 DVD set and during the first
minute 1/2
this is the title screen they used to
introduce Karen Gillan's portion of the
video diaries are you a Doctor Who fan
I'm not I would not say I'm a hardcore
of Whovian if you will I am I love but I
dig that I dig that upon the Christmas
special this year I thought was amazing
I'm if he caught that I did great stuff
anyway Kalen Karen Gillian Gillan plays
his companion on the show doctor always
has a companion on the current of the
current edition you play an Amy Pond on
that show okay I thought it was a nice
nod to our man Kevin Smith by the people
a Doctor Who and I thought since you're
both fans of the show you might like it
Marvin Aguilar synthesis in this is the
actual screen still from the section
where they talk about her you have
joined the common lexicon yeah that's
true they made a porn of it once did
they really I was called chasing Asia it
was for the actress name was Asia
Carrera
but it was close enough have they made
other polls currently a Mallrats with
the Z and I got excited but it has
nothing to do with our movie either way
different version of the stink palm in
that movie there's one in the leads of
that movie ignore you at parties to or
just does it just the real one I leave
his wife spring this email comes from
Mason my name is Mason I just started
college last fall attending the
University of Delaware go Mud Hens
I think I'm not sure what the Megan
Ralph is having a senior moment trying
to think Scott I think it's the mud Blue
Hens Blue Hens maybe found myself the
reserved nerdy type having several bad
Saturday nights
upon listening to your news each podcast
I realize if I could get some common HBO
fans I could really start to enjoy the
entertainment you two so graciously give
away so I humbly request that you relay
a message for me if anyone from the
University of Delaware listens to this
podcast and wants to discuss it with
other listeners please meet me in front
of the Russell dining hall at 7:00 p.m.
on Friday February 10th for dinner
that's [ __ ] pathetic no it's not it's
scary because he says for dinner and
what he means he's gonna eat your
[ __ ] brain he's gonna like let's talk
about Babel you're gonna wake up he's
gonna eat your brain like [ __ ]
Hannibal Lecter man in feed you a piece
remember that part yeah that was the
sequel yeah his name is Mason Francis
you can email him he wants you to email
him if you go to University of Delaware
at ze n ier xeni ER at u de l dot edu
that's where you can reach him message
in a bottle man it's a little sad no
it's cute it's nice reach now it's more
sad than cute yeah still wears underoos
all right keep going through the hole PS
if you don't decide to use this email
you can both [ __ ] off for not taking
three minutes to help an antisocial kid
make some friends well with an attitude
like that Mason I can understand why you
don't have tons of friends
I like it that's a good idea I hope it
works out
let's hear a follow-up he needs to write
back I mentioned try T of anybody
February tens it's like a month away
though he's giving him lots of time to
contact him okay
I could just see him February 10th
standing in front of the Russell dining
hall on campus
and then an hour after nobody comes he's
on the roof of the Russell dining hall
with a sniper rifle
you look like Ralph Garman Garmin they
go like why don't you shoot at Kevin
Smith he's a wider target matter at 7:05
one Friday Fare weekend discover the
biggest wedgie you've ever seen in your
life but that works out man I hope it's
like [ __ ] Sleepless in Seattle he
meets a chick they fall in love they
show up here and their honeymoon I'm
sorry you're a good good person
Shawn Watson another college student
writes from Marion Iowa I love the show
I'm majoring in criminal justice I'm
right on man like Batman I'm pretty sure
Batman didn't major in criminal justice
he could have good he's smart enough he
just never went for the degree because
he was learning criminology and [ __ ] in
the bat game that's it he goes Hudson
University to studies I am taking a
class on sex offenders and my professor
showed us a movie titled Kinsey starring
Liam Neeson I had never heard of it
before today however there's a scene in
which Neeson's character accompanied by
his wife go to the doctor to solve a sex
problem they're having apparently when
they have sex it hurts too much the
doctor asks Liam Neeson how big his [ __ ]
is and pulls out a ruler his wife
indicates that the ruler is not long
enough to depict the length of Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] I could not stop laughing
as I ran through all the leonie's and
[ __ ] jokes in my head it got to the
point that my professor had to excuse me
from the class until I could compose
myself
so how big is Liam Neeson's [ __ ] big
enough to get me kicked out of class
[Applause]
less of a joke more of a fact he adds
thanks for ruining my college education
dicks it's our fault you can't compose
yourself you're on Watson I know we've
always celebrated or I at least have
always celebrated the [ __ ] of Liam
Neeson yeah recently I saw a motion
picture Ralph where there was a [ __ ] on
display that was so luscious it was it
was gigantic it looked like a [ __ ] an
elephant trunk but a cute baby elephant
right which is still way bigger than a
[ __ ] but it's like you know but when you
saw it you weren't threatened all you
heard was like dude it's this movie
called Shane oh yeah it's [ __ ] young
magneto dude it's what Michael
Fassbender Michael Fassbender has a [ __ ]
that would [ __ ] bend time and space
that's Fassbender is oh my god it's yeah
I'm not even kidding dude I literally
pause that on a big-screen TV and I went
up there and did this test and like put
it over his dick like I'm crushing your
knight I put it over his dick like this
right and then I put it from his [ __ ]
knee to his leg same length it's huge
you see his dick up and down that movie
man and it's loud and [ __ ] proud if I
was that dude
I would only make movies where my dick
was being shown no wonder he agreed to
full frontal nudity no kidding and no
kidding this dude should be getting a
lot bigger roles a lot bigger holes
because my god I don't I don't envy
anybody has to [ __ ] this man
Michael Michael ass bender they should
thank you so much we're having that at
the ready and lastly this email comes
from Scotland we've talked about in the
show before but apparently there are
some just just wrong headed Scotsman who
are making a fan film based on this
podcast yes called Babylon begins and
they've been filling us in on every
stage of their production they sent us
some stills from the set from the actual
film yes this week apparently I'm not
sure we showed a couple weeks ago we
showed the two actors were playing us in
the film this is from a scene in the
film that any time exactly was but I get
the sense it's sort of a pre-show
meeting before we do this show it's them
talking okay just like you know the
pre-show meetings we have here yeah when
I'm waiting for you to show up and you
run up 30 seconds later we come on stage
the it's not so much a pre-show meeting
as a will he show yeah that's right
here's a shot of fake Kevin this is the
actor playing Kevin and apparently as I
can tell he's very very focused very
intent it bums me out because it looks
like he's also very thin he's a just I
look at him like I wish I look like that
guy got that intense Kevin Smith look at
his facial we're actually working out
some comedy bits before the show yes and
this next shot is my reaction to your
conversation which is pretty lifelike as
well let's see Ralph's character downing
an entire bottle of Jack Daniels while
the conversation is going on and I
resent that I resent it because he gets
the drink out of the bottle where I have
to use a glass and I don't think that's
fair yeah yeah well that you can when
they screen the movie you can feel like
there's no truth in this art it's right
I would only drink from a glass a bottle
is for over ami and a lot of people
emailed this week on me right now and I
went too far back back to the 22 a hobo
and a boy I know
23 skidoo and all that a lot of emails
this week to let me know that David
Bowie's birthday is tomorrow
apparently January 8th you know old
anybody know Bowie
he's 65 years old so he's officially a
senior citizen fish Lee a senior citizen
I get the disc guy gets get in the
movies cheaper yeah finally he can
afford to go to the movies
a lot of people are asking if I would
give him a tribute so I think it's only
appropriate since I stolen the man's
voice for so long so I'm drinking I
[Music]
[Music]
think Evan just came all over the floor
I'm done you're done that's that
sometimes I think you keep that song
going real long until I come well I'm a
thoughtful and generous lover of nothing
else I lost my entire [ __ ] tablecloth
sorry about that now you need it more
than ever
every week we take a look at some a list
actors turning in z-list performances
it's good actors gone bad it's called
exquisite acne
of exquisite dancing with Roman ball I
can only assume this week a lot of
people watching this particular movie
over the holidays because this came in
by the droves people were talking about
this particular slip it on TV and this
North must have been it's called Santa
Claus the movie the movie yeah with I
guess the the salk ins produced the guys
who brought a Superman okay it took
another icon and made a big movie out of
it was not a big success it didn't work
out for him
no Dudley Moore plays an elf yes and
John Lithgow I think was the bad guy he
is the bad guy he is the owner of a toy
company and Dudley Moore gets expelled
from the North Pole because he pisses
off Santa Claus he [ __ ] mrs. Claus or
something I don't know the exact story
I've never seen the film but he goes to
the big city and he tells John Lithgow
the toymaker that he's gonna make toys
for him and that he wants to give them
away like Santa Claus does and that's
where we pick up this scene watch John
Lithgow performance in Santa Claus how
many workers does this product require
just me well no payroll my needs are
simple and bonus to have them until a
cold place to sleep what would it cost
to give them away free oh that's
fantastic
will you turn your face erasers baths
cream
they were made good the remake we're in
yeah all right
this is the sad part of the show oh man
every week we have to say goodbye to
some people in show business who
deserved to be acknowledged because they
accomplished a lot when they're here for
a short time or a long time it's the
Tinseltown steps and now another edition
of
they'll be missed tough one this week
Angelo Bowers was a comedian locally
here in Los Angeles that story very
funny comedian he was just comedians
comedian as they said yeah he performed
a lot locally it wasn't really a big
name wasn't well known but comics would
go and see him to say this guy's a
genius he does great work he was killed
by a hit-and-run driver
on Saturday the 3rd if the guy was drunk
21 year old was drunk behind the wheel
oh they caught him they caught him yeah
he had two accidents in 5 minutes hit
somebody
hit-and-run the first accident then kept
going and had a second accident 5
minutes later and that was the one
Angelo was in where he was killed and it
was a jeep I think yeah I'm like so he
passed away from his injuries the comic
that he was with Josh Adam Meyers is
another comedian here locally is still
in the hospital and they are I think
they've got a Twitter site up or a
website up for help with his medical
expenses yeah and also there's a Twitter
side up I think it's Angelo's jokes or
something like that it is at Angelo's
joke where essentially there he didn't
have but he was such a Comics comic he
was so pure so to speak you have a
Twitter account or a Facebook into any
of that stuff great so they feel like a
lot of his stuff is Gani and I have an
album or anything like that's a lot of
material is just kind of now gonna be
lost for the ages so they were asking
everybody who remembered any of his
stuff to put it up on the site with that
address I think it's Angelo's joke yeah
sad news the the driver the drunk driver
is gonna be booked on murder charges
once his medical condition improves he
was injured as well so I'm glad they're
taking really good care of him in the
hospital so that they could put him on
trial for murder and then put him in
jail for a long time yeah yeah there was
one of the jokes I saw on butchered cuz
I don't I saw it and I remembered it but
bear with me as I put together this is
one Angelo's jokes he said everyone
thinks I'm Jewish at this acting class I
go to it's at Temple Shalom and my
teachers rabbi Marcus
it's a way home but I thought that was
very funny to a lot of our British
listeners wrote in and said they wanted
to mention Bob Holness he was the host
of a game shop of blockbusters in the UK
for many many years he died at the age
of 83 this week he worked a bunch of
television radio but he's best known
outside of this game show that he did as
being the second actor ever to portray
James Bond he did a radio play based on
the book Moonraker it was only the
second time anyone ever played James
Bond 1956 before they even start the
movies the book Moonraker was written in
1900 all the books were written before
they started making the movies yeah so
he passed away this week you know the
first actor ever played James Bond was
well a TV movie was TV movie no on CBS
1954 Barry Nelson was the guy's name
remember the shining yes
the guy who hires Jack Nicholson to take
over the hotel they did an American
version of James Bond in 1954 on CBS and
it was Casino Royale but they
Americanized them they called him Jimmy
bond and he was an American secret agent
yeah Jimmy bond see Jimmy bond 21 I win
scene painting didn't the net go nearly
as fun and lastly this week Bob Anderson
died you may not know the name but you
know this man's work he was a former
British Olympic swordsman who died at
the age of 89 this week he was he was an
award he was a gold medal winner in the
Olympics but went on to choreograph and
stage swordplay scenes in movies for the
rest of his career he did movies from
rush with love die another day the James
Bond movies a Princess Bride Legend of
Zorro Lord of the Rings trilogy Pirates
of the Caribbean the first one but he's
best known and he wouldn't be known at
all wasn't for Mark Hamill he was Darth
Vader during the lightsaber fights he
did all of light of the Darth Vader's
lightsaber battles and George Lucas
never wanted to acknowledge him wanted
to keep the mystery wanted people to
believe that it was just David Prowse I
guess in the costume right
yeah but mark hamill stepped forward one
day in an interview in 1983 and said Bob
Anderson was a guy did all Vader's
fights and it's time that he should be
known he added he worked so bloody hard
that he deserves some recognition to
which I say Mark Hamill you are not
British stop saying bloody big bugger to
win manners guy who was all of us have
been influenced by it to some degree
we've all had maybe not this generation
but my generation we all had a
lightsaber fight yeah so we all imitated
that guys behavior when I see a little
bit of his work for me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fly flew down those heads yeah
let's [ __ ] chuck the rest of the show
just keep watching don't you want to
watch that movies so [ __ ] good you
don't even have to like Star Wars movies
to like the Empire Strikes Back it's a
game operatic it's a wonderful film it
is a wonderful film and while we're
talking about Star Wars it actually
comes up in this week's edition of [ __ ]
that should not be a fan Kevin this
starts I wanted to share this with you
as one of my co-workers told me about
this just today apparently people have
been talking about it for years
but I never heard about before so who
knows maybe you didn't either this comes
from Bart of course [ __ ] that should not
be is when we take a look at movies
where a mistake slipped through bloopers
that someone should have caught at some
stage in the filmmaking but yet made
their way to the screen this is
different because this was intentionally
put there and people have just started
catching it I guess for the past couple
years right mr. clown yeah
this is from Star Trek JJ Abrams Star
Trek the reboot of the Star Trek
franchise get get mr. clown out of my
props and I didn't know this but with
all the crosstalk lately between Star
Wars and Star Trek about what's better
between William Shatner and Carrie
Fisher and stuff I thought this was
interesting that I did not know a Star
Wars character makes a cameo in Star
Trek ya know so we've brought the
footage in I'm gonna bring my trusty
laser point around I want to show you
this footage real quick and you will see
this scene of the Enterprise Captain
Christopher Pike is at the helm at this
point that's a Bruce Greenwood there
there's steering through a bunch of
wreckage and there's starships being
blown apart there's all kinds of flotsam
and jetsam and space flying around and
cross the viewscreen of the enterprise
you see a Star Wars character I think
you'll be surprised to know that was in
let's take a look at the footage this is
on a computer here so I think there's
any audio but here it is coming in here
we had to do this to slow it down if the
enterprise is crashing through stuff and
then there's Spock he's gay I didn't
know that no we're gonna we're gonna
zoom in over here we're gonna get in
real close if you can see it or not
right there
r2d2 yeah r2d2 float around in space
that makes the enterprise hit Luke
Skywalker ship I don't think they should
cross paths you don't cross the streams
man you don't cross Star Wars and Star
Trek something bad will happen yeah I
think George Lucas is gonna sue somebody
that's what I'm saying
I'd be very bad all right time to take a
look at the week's big storylines in
entertainment news with the HBO
headlines
[Music]
graduates the Justin Timberlake and
Jessica Biel they're engaged so right
yeah yeah they have that dating they
have been dating since 2007
like non-stop didn't know they had to
break up earlier and in the past year
huh say she called me
yeah she did but Justin realized he
couldn't live without her and they were
in Jackson Wyoming over the holidays and
you know Jackson Wyoming is the city of
romance and so he proposed to her there
while they were snowboarding and she
said yes and so now they're gonna be
married forever and ever and ever just
like Russell Brand and Katy Perry do you
think there'll be a prenup in this oh
yes really yeah he wouldn't want to just
jump in there if I can dive in just you
know what if it doesn't work doesn't
work but I got a believe but if it
doesn't if it works then there's no harm
no foul doesn't matter you'll never use
that prenup right I know but then
there's always in the back of your head
like you don't trust me man you made me
sign some [ __ ] paper you know I don't
have a prenup and I've no money doesn't
make a difference he's got a ton of
money why not protect well she's got
some money too right so let's all
protect all our money's a little prenup
yeah but if you're like I got to protect
my money from you what are you putting
your dick in that person for you know
protecting your vagina from her you're
protecting your money from her I don't
know it just seems weird to me yeah
Sinead O'Connor here's a perfect example
Nate O'Conner got married eighteen days
later it's all off it's over forget
about it okay well except for this week
apparently they're back together again
Sinead O'Connor talked about getting
divorce from her husband of 18 days
Barry Harwich last week but this week
they decided to give it another go why
because they [ __ ] that's what she
tweeted guess who had a mad love affair
with my own husband last night she
tweeted this week her yes
spent beautiful evening of lovemaking
with nine other than husband I think she
means none other than husband yeah he's
the spell check that would be a tiresome
night of [ __ ] your husband and nine
others who turned up angelically we
decided to be boyfriend and girlfriend
oh it's so nice when husband and wife
decide to be boyfriend and girlfriend we
decided to be boyfriend and girlfriend
again and stay married but we did rush
into it so we're gonna return to
boyfriend and girlfriend she tweeted
then she tweeted again I be siccing ly
happy and go counseling and move in like
a year like regular people I'm giving
you the literal translation here from
the Twitter but stay married and we all
in love and [ __ ] every other day me
husband is big hairy caveman and came to
claim me with his club and now i'm in
cave land yay we both go panto so me all
happy me loved me hubby and he loved me
and [ __ ] who know like it when did she
become bizarro Sinead me no Sinead me
bizarro Sinead me no marry husband now
boyfriend good go girlfriend bad buy me
am Sinead O'Connor
so they apparently are going to live
separately they may move in together in
about a year but they're just gonna date
for now as husband and wife
alright whatever makes it work for them
I guess nothing compares to her it's all
I'm saying follow that ship quick hey
Lindsay loads in the news what a
surprise fire within the clown it's time
for our weekly little Oh Hannah update
[Music]
why don't you come to your senses I
started to feel bad for Lindsay why she
can't get a break
times are tough she started up 2012 in a
bad way on Sunday a 64 year old stranger
came banging at her door demanding to
talk to her she refused his name was
Loni short he's 64 years old he said he
must speak with her she called the
authorities it turns out the 64 year old
man is a very good friend of her stalker
David Kirk or reason he said to police I
just need to explain some things to
Lindsay about David see this guy's a
good friend he's a good stalker friend
he wanted to go to the stalkers subject
and explain things to her he's like that
guy's not a stalker now she's like you
are is like maybe I'm the stalker I'm
the friend of the stop yeah I'm trying
to explain what's going on you want to
explain some things to her with duct
tape and a box opener and some lubricant
and some Drano and I don't know what
happened but the cops showed up and now
she has a restraining order against him
it's hard to be Lindsay Lohan it's
harder to be that guy right about now
that's true he says he's got a message
you know you just wanted to get in there
and be like come with me we'll be what
to live he's coming from the best to
save Lindsay Lohan the year-end lists
are still coming out even as we enter
into the New Year baby names calm has
announced the worst celebrity given baby
names of the year it's a tie for number
one between Alicia Silverstone and
Mariah Carey Alicia Silverstone named
her son bear blue that's cute man
welcome welcome welcome to the big blue
house children's show character he's a
person yeah yeah but when he gets older
you get changes like just call me BB
[ __ ] don't let me tell why BB he's like
my mother named me bear blue bear
she was the lady from clueless his
middle name blue by the way he spelled
BL you good or worse could it be le w
[Laughter]
and of course Mariah Carey or blue I'm
keV fat how are you this is Ralph drunk
and riot carry named her son Moroccan
Scott Canon Moroccan Scott Canon
sounds like a DJ Dan oldies station no I
believe Moroccan Scott Canon composed
the star-spangled banner I believe he
did yes the world's worst baby name
given to a daughter by a celebrity went
to Zuzu peterson who is the daughter of
former Top Chef Just Desserts contestant
Tanya Peterson don't you have that to be
a celebrity in this list at all this is
the winner of Top Chef
just desserts not the whole Top Chef
just the dessert episode other worst
names on the list
mirabela bunny that is Bryan Adams
daughter's name cuts like a knife but
feels so right I guess when you really
really love a woman you would just name
your daughter anything really maybe back
in the summer of 69 and yeah Kevin James
named his son Canon James what is the
Canon where did the Canon become so
popular is it spelled like the other can
no it's not the K Canon with a K gonna
be a gay porn star to call yourself
catalytic eh yeah I'm Canon speaking of
canons Nick Cannon is in the hospital
and not by America's Got Talent
competitors who beat him for being such
a horrible host no he has a mild kidney
failure says his wife Mariah Carey
gentlemen cheering for kidney failure
Nick Cannon in an aspen colorado
hospital after suffering from mild
kidney failure writes a reminder isn't
it kind of important to have your
kidneys work I got to all right this
according to his wife Mariah Carey who
tweeted the following message this is us
in the hospital role reversal
last year it was me attached to the
machines after having dem babies she has
some babies den babies like dem babies I
had those twins oh I thought it was a
good addition no it's not a condition
but somehow immediately she managed to
turn the situation around to make it
about her in one tweet a very bad they
trouble brag they call them tried to
kick me out of the hospital but here I
am pond Abed with mr. C and she tweeted
this picture of Nick Cannon's suffering
writhing in pain with failing kidneys
while she snuggles up next to him in the
hospital bed with him just look at his
face he's like get the [ __ ] out of this
bed and take this hat off of me I don't
care you tweet your picture I might be
surfing my piss organ is my busy organs
or Christmas is you out of my bed she
tweeted again we're doing okay but
stranded in Aspen oh [ __ ] you guys
kidneys are shutting down you're
bitching about where you're stuck and
you're in Aspen what a rich people live
baby less the altitude it just goes down
the hill this kidney will be fine it
will be Celebrity Apprentice reality
show news they just announced their list
of Celebrity Apprentice contestants who
will be battling to see who will work
for Donald Trump here's your Celebrity
Apprentice list that February 12th aunts
on NBC it debuts Clay Aiken will be
competing once again celebrity is a
relative term
no in that dude he was on American
American Idol yes he came in second I
think what America night oh really who
won Ruben Studdard if I'm not mistaken
was he on the show he is not a show no I
guess click it's doing pretty good yes
he is Lou Ferrigno is on the show this
week don't get angry
you wouldn't like that's the hall
neither taught me the time I stop I try
my best in the challenge to really bring
the much money as I could and I just
hope you won't find in these I'm sorry
Lou but you're fired
I'm throwing I didn't mean it when we're
done
no you're fired do not dance again I'm
sorry when will they know you're fired
don't see they'll eat everything George
Takei star star trek pain mr. Sulu oh my
oh my Lou Ferrigno
[Laughter]
that faces the boner from some of the
women Teresa Giudice come on Teresa
Giudice she invented the dreidel get
that on the way home ask your Jewish
friends about it you'll be very
impressed she's on Real Housewives of
New Jersey apparently yeah
Victoria Gotti daughter of crime boss
John Gotti don't across her is that yeah
I was gonna say shouldn't you just win
by default
Debbie Gibson pop star Debbie Gibson oh
that's out of the blue yeah she she's
gonna win only in her dreams
Aubrey Aubrey O'Day she's a pop star
I guess Tia Carrere her she's yeah she
does that she doesn't show with our
landlord from time to time Jon Lovitz
yeah they're good friends Cheryl Tiegs
model Cheryl Tiegs okay former
supermodel Cheryl Tiegs had the poster I
had the boner
no I meant I had the poster I put the
whole in fun sports illustrated swimsuit
issue she did yeah she was wearing like
a like a mesh-like bathing suit I
remember I did that issue to Patricia
Patricia Velasquez who's uh as you can
tell she's a big hit with the with the
fans she apparently is the first ski
people or on this show how many people
I've never watched it I mean contestants
they start off I don't have an exact
number here's like a lot it was a lot
keep going and going trucha Velasquez is
a Brazilian supermodel I think she's
known bisexual had a longtime affair
with Sandra Bernhard remember her the
I'm just saying mr. universe diana
torres to be mendoza torres from
comedian Lisa Lampanelli
and Gillette Paul Teutul senior of
American Chopper
Arsenio Hall racecar driver Michael
Andretti rock star Dee Snider and
podcaster comedian Adam Carolla we'll be
doing that's a lot of contestants so
what is the idea they all start one by
one e fires yeah they they ought to
compete in tasks and try to raise money
for charity and stuff and then Donald
Trump comes in and waves is here at him
or something he whips his hair back and
forth in bar talk about reality shows
Mackenzie Phillips it was on Celebrity
Rehab of course from one day at a time
she's on a new trouble based reality
show that's gonna be on Oprah Winfrey's
Network it's called extreme clutter
I'm glad to see Oprah Winfrey is raising
the bar of television one her own
network with extreme clutter and that's
just one of those you have a real messy
like a horde and yeah she says that she
started collecting stuff when she got on
the wagon stop doing drugs she started
collecting stuff and now her house is on
unclutter Abul okay so she's gonna host
the show and then I'm gonna be on it
she's got a problem they have - oh so
it's not even Chiefs letter her she's
not the host the patient yeah she's the
first celebrity guest on extreme clutter
extreme clutter there should be like
[ __ ] on fire and stuff of your house if
it's extreme flood it's like people
jumping motorcycles over your
[ __ ] of its extreme clutter like why
won't you throw out that tire like I can
it's mine that's not extreme now I'm
sure it's not extreme but it's just like
books and [ __ ] it's nice
extreme clutter would be like a billion
used rubbers yes that's extreme like
don't look don't take them they're my
babies they got a right to life director
David O Russell's in trouble he of
course the reaction we all know David's
cousin up there didn't hear about it
yeah holy [ __ ]
he dragon of course the fighter yes he
did he was at Sun that same year we were
with clerks 1994 he debuted with a movie
called spanking the monkey yeah I was
right after that he did a movie called
flirting with disaster
he three kings yeah it's an awesome
movie really good filmmaker putting with
disaster question was if you've never
seen a sort of a weird psychosexual
movie about people with weird
peccadilloes and family that's right
apparently David O'Russell has his own
weird family sexual peccadilloes he was
in trouble with the police in Florida
for molesting his 19 year old
transgender niece in a Florida gym they
were I know that's a lot to absorb
yeah headline we're up to wrap our heads
around the step-by-step so follow us if
you can't that's yeah I'm follow the
bouncing ball as we talked about this
headline David a Russell the director is
in trouble was being interviewed by the
Florida police in Broward County for
groping his 19 year old transgender
niece in a Florida gym at a hotel it was
a hotel gym in Florida let's go
backwards a hotel gym in Florida where
he groped his 19 year old trans
under nice now when you say transgender
used to be his nephew is now his niece
and any he grabbed his nieces well let
me get into the the meat of the story
his niece who now goes by the name of
Nicole Peloquin used to be Nicholas
Peloquin okay fair enough
said to the Broward County Sheriff's
Office that while they were working out
David O'Russell offered to help her with
her ab exercises his hands moved down to
her private parts she says then Russell
slipped his hands under her shirt and
felt her breasts that she has grown due
to some hormonal activity I'm sorry
magic pre-op she's pre-op she has not
had the full surgery to to transfer from
male to female yet okay
here's a picture of Nicole by the way go
and take a look at her she looks every
bit the woman looks every bit the
white-trash Florida woman but still sees
every bit the woman she's cute she is
cute you can't blame him right no so the
sheriff's come to him and say look it's
19 but she's your niece now that's not
fair sir now Russell was interviewed by
the sheriff's and he said my niece was
acting very productively towards me that
was his answer she invited me to peel
her breasts he told the sheriff's I have
to admit I was curious about her breast
enhancement he added David Russell and
fatica Lee denied he did anything wrong
he also said that she made him pinky
swear about the breasts touching part
well if she made a pinky swear folks you
really can't bring it up in a court of
law what do you mean she
pinky swear he claims that she let him
feel her breasts and then said pinky
swear you won't tell anybody that I let
you feel my breasts and then she went
told the sheriff's [ __ ] so he's got the
pinky swear to face yes
Your Honor I'd like to say that my
client was asked to pinky swear before
he touched the defendants breasts this
case is dismissed
thank you your honor however the chef's
Department says that they won't be
bringing any charges against him because
there were no witnesses to the incident
just the word of a 19 year old
transgendered niece but that's not
enough apparently not in Florida they
got real [ __ ] up [ __ ] to deal with in
Florida come on now we'll just take him
out with a double tap though that was
Gwyneth Paltrow has her website GUP
common if you guys are regulars on goop
I go to a goop website that's very
different than us she says she's kicking
off 2012 with a cleansing diet and she
wants you all to join her apparently
Gweneth wants to go from 47 pounds to 43
pounds and so she is going on a
cleansing diet I'm starting off with
cleans the name of the cleanse my go-to
cleanse from dr. Alejandro younger
sounds Lee works on the back of a panel
van who goop has partnered with for the
month of January use clean lose a few
pounds and kickstart the year with a
healthier more energetic New Year quinna
feds okay time stuff requited Paltrow
where she's selling us shamans remedies
now of the back of a van is she do you
have to pay to do this it's a month it's
just a month to cleanse right it's just
$425 if you want to get clean oh I
thought it was like one of those things
like I'm gonna [ __ ] put the syrup and
cayenne pepper it is but you got to buy
all the stuff from dr. Junger before you
can't just buy food store you know know
a little bit of Schilling there I'll be
doing it all month with members of the
goop team
I don't want to be on the goop team I
was in junior high school and it was not
fun a lot of clean up on the group team
man
hey that porn star Kim Kardashian news
no he loved the Kardashians so much so
they have their own theme
[Music]
boys are Kim Kardashian this week told
French he wants to adopt a baby because
her relationships aren't working out
he's afraid she won't be a mother oh
you're a mother all right Kim
also Amber Rose used to date Kanye West
said this week that Kim Kardashian
cheated on Reggie Bush with Kanye West
while Amber Rose was still dating him
Jesus walks amber said she'd like to
thank him for being a homewrecker
because now she's found true love with
Wiz Khalifa I like that song first dance
at our wedding also New York Post
announced that Kim Kardashian and her
family are talking to publisher American
media incorporated about the Kardashian
the magazine this is the publishing
company that does star in shape and
National Inquirer they're going to this
spring launched the Kardashian magazine
I mean I guess the idea is like there's
so much coverage of them in the other
magazines why not just go to the well we
need more information about the
Kardashians so I'm glad they're putting
out a magazine don't look just don't
look speaking the don't look Justin
Bieber's got some new ink if you saw
that this week or not please say it's a
Jesus tattoo please say it's a Jesus
tattoo let's take a picture of him on
the beach here in Los Angeles this past
weekend it's on his SOP his left calf
can we get a close-up of that calf James
can you zoom in all the way
[Applause]
your prayers of an answered Kevin it is
in fact a picture of Jesus on his calf
it is the very same Christ head that my
mother wears around her neck on a
medallion it's this big she's way into
Jesus and apparently shows the beam he's
into geez Ari if you put them down on
your calf that's like it's almost like
well yeah Jesus is not quite my co-pilot
but I let him carry my bags yeah
plus if you get attacked by a shark and
he takes your leg then [ __ ] the Jesus
is gone still with you in the sharks on
the beach you don't think yeah well he's
at the beach ma'am can we go back to
that first picture by the way look at
this scrawny ass look at that he's like
he should be on a commercial with Sally
Struthers asking me to donate money to
give him a meal oh my cap that my cab
this is why this is back yeah he's a
scrawny dude but he's got Jesus looking
over his cap so he's got that gun front
movie news sequel mania continues in
Hollywood just announced Paranormal
Activity another Paranormal Activity in
the works
well that makes sense yeah they're easy
to make they're inexpensive to make it's
just printing money last time it was a
baby right got Joe that's right this
time it's the dog I think family dog is
possessed in this one Horrible Bosses a
sequel to Horrible Bosses
seems like they make sequels sometimes
to movies that like they did okay are
good for the first time around but like
aren't really necessarily good counties
especially they're so cheap to me yeah
then I guess they figure on the brand
once you have a brand name you can build
on it so look forward to horribler
bosses I guess coming to a theater near
you it was it was sir
who was that I don't mean to correct you
yeah I thank you for coming to the show
but it was a very very bad film I still
love you movie news to be more is
working again I guess since says she and
Ashton broke up she figured she'd do
something else with her life and go back
to acting yeah she's gonna be in a porn
kinda no no she is gonna be an important
she's not gonna be the porn what it go
ahead tell me the life story of Linda
Lovelace who was in deep throat which is
a porn and cute but it's not a porn I
said it's kinda she's playing Gloria
Steinem feminist icon Gloria Steinem
who's very anti porn I know but the
whole movies about porn yeah but she is
not going to do the porn no she say no
no no - porn Gloria Steinem that's good
that's a good call Amanda Seyfried is
gonna play the Lovelace there's two is
like asteroid picture battling battling
Linda Lovelace biographies we've never
seen any movie but Linda Lovelace now we
got to we're gonna come out at the same
time and Amanda what do you have diaper
it's ciphered is in the wand and Malin
Akerman you say Malin I say Malin okay
what do you say now now yeah I don't
know but you might be right I don't know
I think she's from South Africa from the
north north limbs or something like this
she's like like a biking girl she's
doing the other Linda Lovelace movie and
they've got competing co-stars because
you know in deep throat yeah it started
very popular of at the time porn actor
named harry reems was the star that no
in the Matteson well she was actually
the story of the film yes but he was the
established porn star yeah amanda
seyfried version Adam Brody will be
playing
he's a good harry reems and in the Malin
Akerman version Adam Goldberg will be
playing Harry Reid director - yes Elton
John biopic in the works you want to see
the life story of Elton John as long as
its warts and all yeah like anal warts
or what oh I'm just saying yeah Elton
John has announced he's like Justin
Timberlake to play him well I'm sure you
would open I'd like George Clooney to
play the version of me in the movie but
just just not realistic Justin
Timberlake apparently he's good friends
with Elton and they've done some work
before and he thinks he'd be the perfect
guy to play him in the movie yeah Elton
John you are a fat balding Brit and
Justin Timberlake is a handsome thin and
also it's probably doing his younger
life not that he was an apple has
announced a lawsuit against the company
that is making a Steve Jobs action
figure that is a misnomer if I've ever
heard one even even when Steve was alive
he was an action figure really he would
stand on stage and hold up a I pad for
the most part but they have announced
the eye icons line apparently called is
making a Steve Jobs action figure
Apple is suing them saying they own the
rights to his likeness and that if you
do produce this you will be sued but the
problem is they've already released it
apparently it's alright it's going it
was a $99 toy and now it's going on eBay
for two hundred and twenty-five dollars
a piece because apparently it's gonna
cease and desist sometime soon have you
seen pictures that look like it here's a
here's a shot of the toy it's pretty
good yes it looks like all around his
wrists but other than that he does have
a kind of GOG hole GI Joe wrist yeah the
ipad grip is
public figures okay you just make that's
their defense but they've already shut
down another manufacturer who is making
a Steve Jobs actually figure prior to
that so apparently there's some legal
precedent to this so they may win the
case so order soon if you want your
Steve Jobs action figure so you can
battle Wonder Woman this we're talking
about geeks
sauly time for the geek news of the week
[Music]
it's been a lot of talking about who
will play the villain in the next Star
Trek movie JJ Abrams has announced that
it will be Benedict Cumberbatch yeah
listen to the excitement
Benedict Cumberbatch shall bless you
who was other if you saw the Stephen
Hawking movie the TV movie about Stephen
Hawking's life called Hawking mmm-hmm he
you started Stephen Hawking in that you
ever see the BBC series Sherlock Holmes
the updated Sherlock Holmes he plays
Sherlock Holmes here's a shot of mr.
Cumberbatch right here as Holmes there
you go
you'll be playing the major villain in
the next Star Trek movie so Benedict
Cumberbatch will be your new Star Trek
villain with a name like Benedict
Cumberbatch he should have been in a
hurry Potter movie I think Cumberbatch I
keep your advanced potions if he's the
Defense Against the Dark Arts teacher
yes then he turns out to be the bad guy
how dare you spoiler alert only in some
of the books and also those movies are
done who hasn't seen those movies me I
saw the first one you never saw the rest
no I'm sorry [ __ ] magical wrong yeah
no not even with that just like they're
pretty good pretty cool yeah I'll get
around to him yeah I got a snack a porn
like this I hadn't worked my way through
I got my own magic wand more geek News
akhirin he manga fans in the crowd
they're doing a live-action version of a
Keira that apparently has been shut down
by Warner Brothers they stopped
production on this thing long time ago
it was supposed to start Garrett Hedlund
from Tron and Kristen Stewart but they
just closed the offices in Vancouver the
production offices according to The
Hollywood Reporter due to budget
problems and varieties saying it's
because there's script issues some
people are saying because people are
working on the film realised Kristen
Stewart's a horrible [ __ ] actress
we don't know which one is she Kristen
Stewart's from my Twilight she's the
girl from while and she's not bad
actress I know it's like everyone don't
like Bellinger because it's popular to
bash but she's actually pretty decent
actors did you see that runaways
horrible really yeah well I mean don't
trust my opinion I hire bad actors all
the time that's true hey wait a minute
the hobbits coming out in a year more
walking each exit is bringing us part 1
of The Hobbit a year from now
December 14th - well trailer did you see
the trailer I did yeah very impressed I
like that dude - the dude who plays
Bilbo this time around yeah he was in
the office yeah I know I can't think
yeah not everyone is happy about this
film there is already a boycott going on
what from [ __ ] Mordor now if you
don't just boycott Mordor Ralph it's a
group called Christians for immoral
America Christians for a Mordor America
no not moral moral America so the only
thing is gonna keep these people online
as a [ __ ] eye of Sauron Christians
for a moral America claim that Peter
Jackson is an admitted atheist and so
he's sucking all the Christ out of The
Hobbit story yeah those little guys with
the hairy feet you don't want them not
talking about Jesus they do all the time
in the book well maybe they can
compromise and all the hobbits could get
tattoos of Jesus's head on them for
their cabs good very current
they claim that Jackson who is an
admitted atheist is Satan's little
helper we so wait they're saying that
he's literally draining the Christ out
and also like at number one there's not
a
ton of Christ in these books No number
two they're saying he's taking it all
out right trying to sow the seeds of
anti Christianity he's saying there he's
using Witchcraft and Wizardry in this
film
wait a minute Witchcraft and Wizardry in
in uh in the Lord of the Rings story I
find that hard to believe
me too man I'm not so sure [ __ ] you that
was dude they also complained that he's
bringing everyone back from the Lord of
the Rings like they're coming back from
the dead yeah I don't think they
understand it's a prequel sir I think
that's the problem with their logic
maybe they haven't read the books they
say Christians will not tolerate this
blatant anti-christian bigotry and
Atheist propaganda our children's minds
are filled with enough poison these days
from the media without us as parents
actively doing the same while filling
liberal fatcats
coppers taking them on yeah well I hope
he has the wisdom to take all the
wizardry out of the Tolkien books
because that just has no place in there
I
yeah come on [ __ ] off dude like there
those are real first world problems man
where you're just like we think that the
Hobbit should have way toward Jesus you
know it's hard to be a Christian these
days when these people are running
around claiming that they speak for
Christians no it's yeah and it's they're
really reaching the bottom of the barrel
man when they're just like let's go
after this now
movies not even out don't even know what
the movies gonna be about for Christ's
sake these people also said there was
enough Christian in Yentl apparently
they said that I think they're missing
the point
some movies because hey if you're
looking for a gift to get me for
Christmas and I know most of you are not
the man great no but it's a great gift
start saving now for this Christmas
coming up yeah Kevin yes they are now
making the actual Tron light-cycle from
the movie Tron will it be street-legal
it is street legal
it is $55,000 they make it per order and
it is completely electric it runs
totally on an all electric motor system
how fast yeah it does not say here how
fast it goes but it goes fast trust me
because it's a light cycle goes like the
[ __ ] speed of light or whatever it is
I saw the movie leave the tail behind
you so you can make cars crash okay
because that a lifting that would be
worth it for me it's just because then
you could be a real offensive driver run
people into your tail watch them blow up
in your Ruby Parker Brothers choppers is
making the actual light cycle from the
2010 film Tron Legacy lithium-ion
battery powers the whole thing it lights
up it's got that cool look I brought in
some footage of the actual bike going
down the street if you want to see it
but
yeah he's gonna get all the Lee's
alright there's no room for a lady on
his bike but and yet the lay down when
you ride it looking put to speed up
look at that
oh that's so sweet yes so sweet the
problem is that's like a poet that we're
in a post Batpod world so I see that in
the mic that's nice but I'd rather of
the Batpod man we have that theme you
all know one loves so well and can
humming you really miss out on him Ralph
Garman presents the bridge bridges
go blue Jeff Bridges had a baby B Jeff
Bridges are we talking about Doctor Who
earlier this woman's a Doctor Who fan
and it's Erika Quinn she turned her
house in Glasgow Scotland into the
TARDIS yeah here's a photo of Eric
outside the front of her house she
painted her front doors to look like the
TARDIS oh look at her Oh Erica I weed
for you Erica that's the front door of
her house in Glasgow she has life-sized
cardboard cutouts of the doctor in her
window along with all of his companions
a Dalek is also there she dresses them
up with different costumes for Christmas
Thanksgiving Halloween and Easter she
says people walk by and just stop and
stare at my house people have started
calling me the Doctor Who house lady
yeah that's what they're calling you
it's the doctor who else lady who said
with many cats and I want to thank all
the listeners this week who sent us the
pictures from geeks are sexy net the
website apparently they did a story I
know who the artist is who did it you
get these - yes cute it is a guy who
came up with the idea what if dr. Seuss
had created Batman so it is the dr.
Seuss take on many Batman characters
I've brought in a couple photos of those
you hadn't seen it yet this is the first
one is Batman it's uh I had trouble in
making my way down crown like Crime
Alley it says there is sort of perch
looking sort of sad holding a bat around
holding a Batarang the next one's the
Joker a funny thing happened on the way
Arkham Asylum and my favorite one by far
is two-faced because I think this could
be an actual Seuss book 50% Harvey Day
[Laughter]
alright it's the end of our show folks
thanks so much for coming out but before
we say goodnight
[Music]
liam neeson stock you can add your own
if you have any facts about Liam
Neeson's constant nice and calm this all
comes of course from Kevin Smith's
fascination or least until he saw
Michael Fassbender talk about this
yourselves a favor go look at Shane
that's the move just to see his [ __ ] but
the performances are good and it's a you
know as a painful meditation on sex
addiction but [ __ ] all that his dick is
just like a baby [ __ ] orangutangs
aren't holding an apple holding a grape
last week we had the guy with the
Pringles can you read with now we got
there Michael Fassbender Kok you're
getting a bit of a reputation I'm always
amazed by that cuz like this dude he has
like such a dangler like a third [ __ ]
we understand he's got a big penis
gifted from God like here have a massive
dick for your whole [ __ ] life
that's that's all you need in life like
he got that one thing then he also got
to be an actor he got to things it's
unfair man you're gonna have to dig that
big leave some some mouths for other
people you don't know how he lives is
like you don't know what he has to deal
with well might have hemorrhoids or
something you don't know it might have
something bad going on - man he's in
shape and [ __ ] I'm telling you I think
he did that movie just as a commercial
it'd be like wait so you see my dear
yeah it's not enough to be a movie star
now he's gonna get all the ladies right
well Liam Neeson before this week was
Kevin's [ __ ] crush and so we've taken a
look at the size of Liam's [ __ ] and come
up with some fascinating facts Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big even Oliver
Twist pushes away from the table it says
please sir I've had enough come on Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
he can pay at the first window and pick
up his food at the second window at the
same time Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
even Tom Cruise uses a stunt double when
filming on it Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big how big is it Janice Dickinson is
still [ __ ] she of course was the
famous yes she's the one he's hung like
a evian bomb that's was her with the big
one the big one Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big when he orgasms the woman's body
expands like Violet Beauregarde in Willy
Wonka & the Chocolate Factory
[Music]
I think the amis Singh came inside you
like a [ __ ] little pig maybe you
should put the [ __ ] down then you won't
be so bad
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
we should practice go Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big Oh Liam Neeson is the only man
alive who's too long to fly Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
Wow Liam was originally cast in The
Bridges of Madison County
as a bridge Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
it's knock knock knockin on heaven's
door Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
it's needs outweighed the needs of the
many Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
Katy Perry recently saw it for the first
time nuff said Liam Neeson stop see
that's why the rustle Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big that his Bush has pygmies Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that when he
gets a rent groups of people begin to
chant does she does she buzzer buzzer
when asked what it means he responds
rise we at Lisa's [ __ ] is so big
he doesn't pee his pants when he's drunk
that's coolant to keep it from
overheating we talked about him pee his
pants last week mother Perry we got
quite a few of those Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big that when he's done peeing he
doesn't shake it he throws it over his
shoulder and burps it tell your mother
that wouldn't I'm gonna calling her up
on the word home ma'am mama give the
best Liam Neeson's [ __ ] to Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big that Liam Neeson has to
use a megaphone to tell you how pleased
he is with your dick sucking Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big but in
conversation Jon Lovitz will casually
name-drop that he knows it you guys like
to mention his famous friends yes and
lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it
doesn't need diplomatic immunity
ladies gentlemen guys of a good time
tonight thank you all for coming out for
the first battle on for the New Year
from keep coming back it works to be
working for Hollywood babble-on I'm
Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman battle the
[ __ ] on everybody good night
ladies and gentlemen give it up one more
time Kevin Smith and the Ralph Garman
Hollywood babble-on
live at beloved's alright kids that's
gonna do it for us
[Music]